[Music]
he understands
I'm Leonid Euler from Entertainment
Tonight and joined once again by the
amazing Katrina bath and Sam heughan
and we are going to be giving all of the
juicy secrets about Outlander season
three it's coming up just so excited
because Voyager has so many different
plot twists so many different things
happens in this book are you guys
surprised to see how they've been able
to fit it all into all the episodes it's
been really great this season it feels
again very different I think that's the
great thing about our show is every
season feels very unique and it has you
know its own unique journey within it
and so it's been quite strange I guess
Sam and I have been apart for the first
bit of it they spend so much time apart
I mean decades apart and they've become
different people and they have lived
other lives and so yeah it's been it's
been really fun as you said it's
completely different it's not like we're
doing the same show each season it
really changes I've been working a lot
with sophie Skelton and with Tobias and
that has been great and you know that
relationship between Clare and Brianna I
think is really strong this season which
is wonderful I've been working in a cave
with yourself oh my gosh well and we've
got to talk about the aging process what
has that been like for you guys and
what's it been like to see each other
with a few more lines on your face and
wisps of gray hair they donate it all do
you think eternal use I think we you
know I'm certainly from Jamie sack we
approached it through no not making him
grey with a walking stick and Anna limp
though I think that's good idea but uh
well you know it's more the experiences
and what happens to you know for Clara
again I think we've seen her sort of
from the end of last season in the 60s
and it's gonna be something very similar
to that but it is that beautiful thing I
mean we we've sort of gone through
little vignettes of her life without
Jamie so you'll see her in the 40s and
the 50s and the 60s and it's been really
interesting
paying Haydn's how does a person change
in their lifetime or what are the
moments in their life that kind of help
them become this this woman that we meet
finally in the 60s so it's been it's
been an interesting challenge I think
for both of us I wish I'd done the limp
you should have done the limp it's not
too late it's not I could kick your shin
right now and because we have so many
fresh faces joining the show in season
three who are you guys most excited for
the fans to get to know and have you had
any light Outlander hazing of the
newbies on set I mean I wouldn't want to
have you give away too much but I
certainly feel there's been a little bit
of maybe slight bullying of the younger
ones than you once better going on and
definitely a hierarchy you'll have to
tune in to watch out find out well and
lastly what do you feel like is going to
be the most challenging aspect of season
three meeting the expectations I think
definitely you know there's there's some
tall orders been delivered from the fans
so but I think we can do it I think
we're gonna Surprise them I think that
they have an idea of the book so
obviously we were following the books
but there's so many more surprises than
than they're even contemplating well and
then just jumping off that yeah the fans
were saying that they wish that they had
had a little bit of more romance in
season two do you think that they will
get that satisfaction in season three I
think we always hoped and knew that we
would have a long time to tell this
story and so in that way you want to be
able to tell every shade of this
relationship I mean this is a
relationship that endures decades and
hopefully we will get to tell many many
years of that so you know you can never
you don't want to repeat yourself and
we've seen the blossom of first love
we've seen when they've had an awful lot
of stress on that relationship and now
it's going to be a different type of
reunion I think that people are invested
because they believe in this love that
Jamie and Claire have
so you're definitely gonna see that yeah
perfect
for the latest information be sure to
follow Outlander on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
[Music]